you didn't take care of your money and
they say hey daddy what happened to all
the money
yeah you don't want to hear that why did
you say that
does it happen to you mike yeah
daddy got the money back yeah
[Music]
what's up everybody you guys welcome to
this episode of hop boxing with mike
tyson i am your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
and we here we have such a special guest
we have the great up and coming
shakur stevenson shakur how you doing
brother i'm good i'm just chilling you
know uh
getting ready for this next flight who
are you fighting it's an
african guy's name uh jeremiah tilly
yeah do you have any films of him what's
his record
i think he like 21-1
oh 21-1 yeah i didn't really watch too
much of them you know watching me you
you don't study your part yeah
i i study it just i wish i gained kim
like my
coaches sit me down and we'll sit down
and watch it together yeah and so
how's been how's uh training camping
going with shakur i mean right now we're
in cam right now sometime
i mean i'm getting to camp like uh i i'm
always in the gym so
i'm never really like out of shape but
next week i'm gonna go to colorado
springs
i can't wait uh terence crawford is the
trainer that was the bomb
yeah it's the altitude yeah it was the
bomb yeah
yes yesterday i mean you get so he grew
old quick
yeah yeah that colorado springs man you
do a lot of training camps down there
when you're trained for the olympics oh
yeah that's what uh
all my training cancers at when i was
getting ready for the olympia so you
guys pretty much live out there right
for
yeah your whole year right in the
springs yeah most definitely uh
i'm gonna do eight weeks down there for
this camp then whenever my next fight
come i'm gonna be back down there for
another eight weeks
you're not a guy that goes to big bear
you prefer colorado springs and i like
colorado springs
i like the altitude there yeah and i'm
used to it
well big bear two right big pair is
about the same uh colorado springs is
more sociable than big bears more
isolated
yeah you prefer big bear or carl springs
um cairo's being it's more professional
yeah and cairo spring is just a little
hick
town with some cabins in it you know
this is the brother right here yeah
that's him all right
look at him what part of africa is from
i'm not even africa yeah i'll tell you
what ma'am africa's been on the map man
you see uh francis lugano yeah you can't
investigate anyone
no you can't you gotta take everybody
seriously very serious
dead serious namibia all right let's
check him out let's see his moves
oh he's he looks kind of tall is he tall
yeah he's like uh
5 10 i think you five eight right yeah
i don't think that mattered too much
though no a little about desire
how bad you won it
who's this gentleman do you ever hear of
him you know his name no i don't even
know him
i never even seen this fight oh look at
this
you you don't like to you don't like to
study film i study some film but
i i kind of do it with my grandfather me
and my grandfather watch it together
yeah hey listen right
if this guy laid the glove on you you
should retire
oh [ __ ] no but you know what mikey you
go back to what you said never under it
takes
it takes one blow one yeah that guy
couldn't hit you you were blindfolded
yeah you're right about that
he's tough too though if you come to
fight him he's tough
yeah who would you like to fight after
this shakur
i really want the valdez fight like the
fact
is something that i'm really looking
forward to i wanted to fight him at 126
but
he ended up vacating his belt and moving
up so
i i've watched valdez a lot man what do
you
how would you rank his power i think he
got a lot of power i think he threw a
lot of uh
hard shots but i think that uh later in
the rounds he gas out
yeah come on man we got i'm not he's not
underestimating this guy i
am let's check five days out yeah
have you seen a valdez uh fight before i
hear his name out there
yeah oscar valdez he's a real goodness
he went through the amateurs
he went to the olympics too for mexico
you fight him in amateurs now he never
fight
nightingale
fighting
images he went to uh then he went to two
olympics he went to a couple olympics
yeah he's experienced uh yeah he's from
uh he's from northern mexico and
sonora
that's where the frog comes from he's
scared to fight me though man
he thinks so yeah you know what show his
last uh
uh knockout i think it's this fight yeah
he's just got in this fight
nothing right there
it's two different styles you know both
him and shakur they
have two different styles so it's you
know styles kind of make fights here you
know yeah it depends
who brings their a game i promise you
i'm bringing my a game
oh fm see these guys that's him right
here to open
punch like that yeah so you you can see
these buttons coming out of the way
right yeah yeah because i can see
punches like that when i was fighting
come a mile away
they're hard but they're like slow
motion what round is this
this guy's in the middle of the power
like that he's just standing right in
front of him
he ain't moving his head boom coming
straight forward the move has come
straight forward
and got clogged with his head head in
the air boom
yeah me and my man right here with
technicians
man you miss you want to pay with your
life
man yeah
yeah put them head in their hands out
here not guarding themself
yeah look at him look at him that's
amazing fighting
boom you gotta touch his body too though
yeah everybody's vicious yeah guys can
take it to the job you hit him to the
body hey
what you doing down there right what are
you doing down there
what makes oscar valdez a good boxer i
think he got a lot of will
i think like really aggressive yeah he
got a lot of will
i don't think he really skillfully that
good but you gotta wear something yeah
no and of course when you could never
count that dude no you can't tell the
guys that are willing to die you know
what i'm saying mike those dudes that
are dude those are the most
those are everybody thinks they're
willing to die till they come close to
dying then they realize they're not
willing to die it's dangerous though
when you got somebody that's like
they got both like somebody that got the
heart and got the skill so and how's the
ability
skill in the will yeah yeah it's hard to
beat them
yeah what's your take right now with
everything that's going on with uh with
the 35 division
with the teal female
yeah i can't wait to like i'm near and
i'm at that division to
like being on big fights with them but i
think that is a great division
i think there's a lot of great fighters
there uh i got respect for
a lot of them fighters so why don't you
get some foreign champion like the
english champion uh
some champions from other countries the
chance for the belt
what you mean like get somebody like
fight somebody to fight the english
um junior lightweight champ i don't even
know who the english junior lightweight
champion
check him out he's gotta be beat every
champion in every country
yeah but i feel like like the people in
my like division
i've been trying to like fight the
champs and i feel like none of them want
to fight like who's the champs
right now uh like i said valdez was a
champ at 26.
not when i became his mandatory he
vacated the belt and moved up
now jamel herron he just fought for the
belt he won and now i'm in his mind
141 no he's 130
yeah okay i mean it's mandatory and he
uh now he's going to vacate the belt and
try to fight valdez
you're a scary guy
a scary guy yeah show some of his fights
please
watch the smoothness of him that this
should cause stevenson
i mean i came to see you one day and
jerry there's newark
yeah i met you the first time yeah yeah
i remember
and it's different too because you know
you come from that amateur background so
it's a lot of experience man this
is oh they can't oh
he's experienced fight he doesn't have
to move his head because he as soon as
punch come he
anticipates it all that experience
see ooh see it looks like he's not
moving but you just
oh look at that man who are some of the
guys you've uh you've emulated
that you've taken from probably like uh
panel whitaker
um ray leonard
you look good though son oh
i watch tams crawford a lot too i like
tears
yeah how difficult is is it the way uh
terence crawford's like he's able to
switch to both stands
how how difficult is that coming because
he's been he's been able to master and i
think that's what makes him in my eyes
pound for pound is the fact that he able
he his right and his left are
are both vicious man i think tears just
like he a dog
and like i feel like he got like a dog
mentality so
i just feel like you know he could do
both of that but i know like whenever
he fights mikey garcia one of those guys
who uh mikey garcia your hammer the
other guy he beat him
yeah yeah he'll be mikey he'll be all he
need to fight on earl
how many damn you beat arrow who do you
got on that fight
i can't really say i can't just sit here
uh i ain't gonna uh
say too much i know it's gonna be hard
for anybody to be tennis covered that's
all i'm gonna say
anybody i don't care who it is all right
so you got talents crosses over anybody
who else we got out there
look how beautiful you look you're
slaying these guys
out pull fast hands
yeah they bend his legs
can't hit him but oh and then move
he moves his head right after he punch
just in case a guy come back and get
counted
would you like would you like a match up
with uh oh silly little
shanker yeah i would love to fight uh i
think you should as well you should
i sparred them um to uh
get him ready for rigado uh-huh yeah i
spotted him we did probably like a lot
of we did a lot of rounds in camp
yeah yeah would you think he you like
that match up with you with him yeah i
would love to fight lemonchenko i think
that's a that'd be that'd be a great
fight yeah
especially him coming off his lawson
he's trying to prove himself and
then he gonna get back in the ring with
another young killer so
i think he should do it right we should
promote that one yeah i would love to do
you still feel like he's one of the best
at 130
at 135 i think he's too small for 35. i
think he should come down to uh
130 i think so too yeah i think 130 is
more his weight
i think he'll beat everybody at 130
except me and a tank probably you've uh
you've got you spot with tank before too
yeah i helped
get ready for uh his world title fight
with pedraza
yeah i supported tank before mike that's
what i love about boxing mike is uh
you know a lot of a lot of times even
before you guys fight for world titles
you guys have already sparred against
them already yeah a lot of them already
tested yourself
already i feel like i've been in the
ring with the whole 135 division though
that's good to get familiar with them
yeah how you like daily
uh haley he did the show who haley um
[ __ ]
haney i mean oh yeah that was nice too
yeah i thought you and him
yeah we inspired each other we spotted
each other a couple of times before that
too
what's your take with david he's a great
body puncher
i think that devin haney a good fighter
i think he's a real good fighter i think
he's real skillful
is he the best is he the best right now
35 how you think him and tfo do
i think that's a good fight i think that
uh
devin haynie more skillful but uh tia
female got
on the better power yeah yeah
i think it'd be a good fight though
this guy's like fighting the ghost right
he's constantly going high low on he got
good through that body punches
killing him you don't you don't head
hunt too
nah don't did you fight a mexican that
night
yeah yeah
the people like you were they hating on
you
they ain't like that i did that but i
mean for me
yeah it's an entertainment business so
you got to be entertaining big time
big time and the sooner they know it the
most money they
get yeah i was crazy i'm
talking about people mothers eating
their kids everybody came to see that
[ __ ]
yeah master you're one of nine yeah i'm
one to nine i'm the oldest
yeah i'm the oldest really you know what
is your little brother
that's a trick right yeah only you 21
i'm 23 23 yeah good
i know there's a nine that's a trick you
take care of them man do you help raise
them or what
all the younger ones like staying with
me right now so i do help like raise
them
for me that's that's that's challenging
that's good yeah one of my little
cousins stayed with me too like he boxed
too so
i'll be taking him to the gym me and
taking him
to fights and all that kind of stuff too
so it's good to have a big family yeah
yes cool man are you watching that
canelo billy joe saunders fight
what do you think do you think people
are sleeping on billy joe saunders yeah
i think that billy joel saunders a
better fighter than people give him
let's look at billy joe sanders ass now
have you seen have you seen david
benavidez have you seen david yeah
benovita's
guy right yeah i like him too dude he's
a real deal man yeah he's a beast
he reminds me of um kyle's mind zone a
little bit
man after that can you put david
benavidez
i want to see him fight one of the cholo
brothers yeah he wants to man he wants
he wants to fight all of them
the green right yeah yeah the light
green
no no it's the guy in the it's the guy
in the yellow
oh it looks like green to me
oh yeah yeah i guess highlight [ __ ]
yeah yeah
he can't beat canelo though he's knocked
out right now
he's knocked out already i saw that he
goes right
already knocked out it's just different
dudes
you know like anybody you can just tell
the speed difference
guys can we put uh can we put david
benavidez on yeah he's fun
look up his highlights what the hell
just happened
damn he really clocked that guy throw
the towel in that
[ __ ] look at this guy look he
goes to the body look at look at how he
works with the body mike
boom it's like you just yeah he's though
him and cholo dude
yeah charlotte nice yeah you gotta get
in there with him see how nice he is
yeah you're not gonna believe this man i
used to spar this i used to spot this
guy when he was 11 years old
yeah that's right he was like a big fan
yeah he was
there's videos of me me and him smart i
was 21 because i'm 10 years older than
him
come on man we just gotta play on the
cholo i think we better fight him on
tyson
legends only league
we got a league on fox actually i want
to see him fight uh
caleb plant uh he'll be plant man you
think he'd be
yeah caleb playing good yeah but this
this dude's got everything you already
talked about we're talking about will
and skill
kayla playing can box real good too and
he got power
i think i think the speed and the length
is going to be the difference
in that fight and i think that's why i
would give it to benavidez yeah that'd
be a good fight though
the only one that could be canelo honest
i swear do you think he could beat
canelo i think he's the only one that
could beat him
oh let's do it now baby let's get that
fight going
canelo average canelo alvarez yeah
dude this dude's the youngest uh what is
it the youngest does
the super middleweight is that 168.
probably you're the youngest in history
to win a world title dude
like what uh 17 yeah like something
crazy dude you know what i'm saying you
serve you break records like that you
died a dude like this that's
that's crazy man well fredo bernie was
the youngest champ ever 17.
yeah and he was nice movement
he was nice he was real good
what's your take with uh what would you
take with ryan garcia man is he
is is ryan garcia the real deal man or
is it a lot of young guys
i think ryan garcia is a he's another
one who's better than what what people
give him
like a lot of people would think i think
it's a youtube sensation
yeah but he's a real good puncher all i
think all i think you need to like get
his chin
out the air yeah too high yeah it's
always always high
whoo look at that [ __ ] yeah
well getting to the side you should do
after your jabs
what do you think of the pacquiao
mayweather fight i mean the pacquiao
crawford fight
card we're going to stop him what's yeah
yeah
i don't think so you don't think so no i
mean that's bad for
soda or some [ __ ] whatever
mike you're a big you're a big pocky fan
i'm like
yes well my i think podcast
[ __ ] yeah oh
well listen he ain't gonna get beat up
like you think he is i think he's gonna
get beat up
okay you gotta do you have to say mike
you know so if i'm not even if
yeah did you see mike that uh clarissa
shields is gonna debut for her uh
for for her for her mma fight that's a
hard broad huh
well now she's she's legit like she goes
i've never seen no female like that on
the planet listen i used to know
i've been around say [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i ain't saying [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you think of her debut though do
you think she could make it in mma yeah
i think she could do whatever she put on
mine
i think she had a strong mind like her
mind is like dangerous like
yeah she's killing her head so she looks
dangerous right yeah
i'm scared and that little japanese guy
who's a little chinese girl in um
mma she says yeah she wants to kick my
ass too
jean-weight lee yeah cause i said rose
is hot
you said the roses might i said rose is
hot remember she got five more
rows yeah
i mean i got it like a uh it's like a
love hate like i
it's entertaining to know but like i
don't see it like it's like real
fighting like
i'm a real boxing fan so i would like i
like watching aaron spence and
terence crawford and that but that's the
thing man they got to fight but a lot of
that stuff that's why that stuff is good
because the real [ __ ] don't
want to fight each other exactly
that's why those those guys like um jake
paul
got this jake paul came on my um foot on
my show
you know why because we got 70 mil 75
million [ __ ] viewers
yeah you know that champion's none of
our champions got that [ __ ] so he's good
for boxing
if he's good for boxers is he kind of
ridiculous
yeah but is he good for boxing [ __ ] yeah
boxing knees [ __ ] like that all right so
what you think about
him getting in the ring with another
boxer a real boxer yeah
that's up that's that's that's up to him
he should be trying to body back i think
he should
he should nah but they're playing it up
dude and mike is right at the end of the
day dude
they're they're hyping up the sport your
guy's a sport but but this is another
thing it's going to force a lot of you
good guys to fight each other
yeah because if these youtube guys are
in here they're taking over
money and these guys are not really i
don't know they're well they're real
[ __ ] but they
you know i mean they put the work in
like yoga didn't go through the amazing
process
and all that stuff and they make it more
money than the champs
i agree so you need to fight those
people and [ __ ] them up
yeah but boxers got to fight each other
they everybody be saying no
yo young guys you can fight each other
again yeah if you if
he beats you you fight him again you
beat him fight again
yeah what's your relationship with uh
with andrea wardman he's also uh
he's also your manager right he's a
manager he was my manager my manager jay
prince j
prince yeah yeah but uh andre roy a
great fighter and
he i think he wanted the best fighters
to ever do it yeah i just don't think he
got the credit for it
then he was a nice guy didn't talk [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i took a whole bunch of [ __ ] people
still
hey is that true i don't know man it's
talking
you [ __ ] that fight mike if if uh if he
if uh andre ware comes back for canelo
and he fights him
i would love that that's beautiful right
but it should be at 68.
could uh ward may 68. he made 75 but 68
is beautiful
yeah 475 i mean it could also be
canelo trying to make it yeah but canelo
can't beat andre wood
hey you hear that canelo he said you
could be
anybody else but this brother rj i said
and i'm a big canelo i love canelo but
all right i want to see it happen come
on wood that was that
was that 20 million wood yeah
you know what i think andre ward does
need because i think you're right man
olympic gold medalist i mean he defended
his title for so many times
he went out undefeated yeah but it's
i i i think mike was right mike said he
was lacking a persona he needed he
needed to hype it up and hide
some guys are the greatest fighters in
the world but they ain't exciting
yeah they could beat anybody yeah but
yes
they don't do it looking good yeah yeah
that's even like uh you know a lot of
people
if you really you know it's like floyd's
two fights in the road i could i could
still bring the people because they know
it's gonna be excited
i'm gonna lose excitingly you know
and then i'm gonna talk some [ __ ] and
say they lost because
god was jealous of me for that
particular reason
and then i get another fight
and then my kids go to really cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
schools
man that's what's up dude i think you're
gonna be very successful yeah thank you
i think it'd be very successful yeah
that means a lot coming from you
nah you know you how many amateur fights
you have like
200 300 you see there's 200 fights now
you think that counts for what he's
doing is so good
200 times yeah i personally think that
the amateurs is harder than
actually professional oh absolutely i
agree so you listen
you fight like the first night you fight
the best fighter in the world
the next night you fight the number two
best fighter in the world you never get
an easy fight you're professional you
get 10
20 80 fights before you get a good
opponent you know
yeah you never get easy fighting the
amateurs they be fighting for your
[ __ ] life
right yeah i agree you think well i hope
i fight this guy i want to fight this
guy at the end you know
that you fighting them in the beginning
the first fight like damn
because it's a it's a bracket and you
get like a drawing
you might pull the number one seed or
the number two
three but dick once you beat me up
confidence go up right there all right
hey but yo you know you gotta beat the
[ __ ] everything champ got beat last
night yeah he got beat he got beat
it's a big thing especially overseas
what do you think of uh
uh davis versus garcia man [ __ ]
tank or killer i don't know i don't know
if
ryan gonna be able to take that he
coming at him like that
it's different right yeah come on man
don't just give up garcia
he's going to be throwing those punches
man those ricky ricardo moves and yeah
chin in the air yeah
what do you think is your greatest
accomplishment you think going to the
olympics and you know meddling there
or you think it's uh i don't think none
of my accomplishments
great to me like i don't i i feel like
in my brain
i ain't doing nothing yet like i tell
myself like i ain't do nothing so
that way like i stay focused and stay
like motivated to do more like
so in my brain it's like i ain't doing
nothing like i still ain't
i still ain't accomplished like what i
wanted to accomplish so
i like something like it's cool to like
oh yeah you're olympic silver medalist
so
i ain't i was number two in the olympics
i wasn't number one so i don't
i don't need like hearing that like i
hear it but i don't
i don't think i think it's something
gratitude
and once you receive that gratitude you
accomplish
so much more yeah you know yeah but it'd
be hard for me like it's hard
it's hard life but that's what life's
about overcoming toughness
yeah yeah you know that's what life is
all about
yeah ain't nothing this is one big
school and nothing easy
yeah some of us pass faster than others
and some of us take a long time to pass
yeah
but eventually you're gonna pass yeah
yeah what would you say is contentment
mike
like being is content content doesn't
always have to be a bad thing right
being content with no nobody needs to be
in content the only thing anybody have
to do is do their best
pretend it's a bad thing to me there's
no there's no there's no
room for jealousy and competition yeah
yeah no i get that man i'm a gold
medalist i you know i want the olympics
but i can tell you man it's like
i see a lot of people kind of live in
that shadow because it never
accomplished what they want to
accomplish so what happens is like
they're like bitter there's people like
that you know they're saying like still
in the sport like they still kind of
never lived in their glory days you know
what i'm saying and it's almost like you
have to come to a realization where
you do have to you know accept and and
you know it's not always a matter it is
a time in life that we have to raise our
kids
and then that's bigger than us at least
i believe that's how
most adults look at it i think i use it
as like motivation like
i don't like get bitter like and my
brain is okay you lost
you don't will never feel that feeling
again like that feeling to me is like
something
like too bad that i don't want to feel
like ever again so now i've been working
super hard to make sure i don't never
lose ever again because i don't like it
look everybody's afraid of loss
everybody's talking about lost
life is about loss life is totally about
loss even when you think you're willing
you get your hair is coming falling out
your mother's dying your sisters die
you're losing all of them
and then you lose your teeth you lose
your desire to live and then you die
it's all about loss life
maybe when you think you're winning
somebody got a billion bucks
you can't spend it when you did
you know yeah life is totally about loss
yeah nobody wins through loss is how we
learn right
no loss is beautiful yeah dying's
beautiful
our whole existence was beautiful that's
exactly that's exactly what it is
mike man you know that's like life life
should just be beautiful dude
and it's worth it at its worst even when
we were slaves it was still beautiful
and we can't stop that we're going to
live we're
and going gonna create what you're
taking with what uncle mike what mike's
talking about
yeah i feel mike i get i get some of
what he's saying but
i told you in my head it's like i don't
like love like i don't like losing so
i try to like keep losing out my brain
because for me
so tell me if you've listened you've
lost before and listen
you're more successful now than you you
lost yeah you know
that's the thing who's lost him before
that didn't stop you from becoming who
you are yeah i agree
well it's not going to kill nobody yeah
it even made you better
yeah as long as you give it your all you
give it to all
you know you should be okay with
whatever the outcome is you give it your
order but you give it your arm more
you know this is fighting it's all about
spirit
yeah about how much spiritual you got i
feel like i'm not going to marines
i'm not going to rain i ain't going in
there thinking like
feel me like okay we're going to give my
all and if we lose
no no no no
nobody and rarely does anybody leave on
blemish and boxing
or in anything yeah like you know what
i'm saying like i i trust me i got my
listen championships
win as many as you can yeah right that's
the real deal
yeah championships yeah hall of fame
yeah living immortality that's what this
is all about
living forever what advice would you
give uh you know shakur now that is
obviously your older mind you went
through the whole boxing ranks
what advice would you give shakur man
since you know and and this and this
boxing
only thing you need in boxing is a
trainer and a lawyer
yeah you don't need no man there's
usually nothing the trainer
and look some people want magic because
they like to keep people around them and
stuff
but you know all you need is a lawyer
and your trainer and whatever
anybody have to talk to you about you
talk to this guy what do you know about
business just talk to this guy
yeah that's what i wish i did you want
some guys to hang around you give them a
job
you just don't hang around if it's just
it's him just being a psych man
jumping on your dick hanging out with
you that's a job that's a job too
you don't have nobody freeload on you
and make them
if these people in your life and they
don't have a purpose in your life what
the [ __ ] they doing in your life
yeah you know that's just keeping it
real and sometimes it's hard to tell the
homie home
hook up your money i got to move man hoe
stay here
they have to have some business now he's
not handling any business
yeah i'm handling some business he needs
to i know learn how to
respect that yeah you don't respect that
yet
yeah when you go they know they going
with your attacking mom sometimes you
have to distance yourself
yeah and you can still be cool with them
but you know
you can't have these guys breathing on
you all the time yeah
you can't even [ __ ] a [ __ ] without them
knowing and then telling somebody on you
yeah so keep it real man yeah i got you
yeah you know you have to do some some
things private everybody can't know what
the [ __ ] you doing
yeah you know how can you be a man and
these guys do you think your friend that
[ __ ] black man you don't give a [ __ ]
about you
but you're a nice kid anyway so what
else do you like to do
how you like christmas you have to make
holidays i'm a family man
all right
i got my little brothers and stuff and i
stay around my family and stuff like
that
i am joking you had to kiss the family
with you when you left that thing too
yeah yeah yeah i'm a big family man
that's how you you should spend your
money with this family yeah
you know if you're a family man like
that you should save up for a house for
all of us to live in like a compound
yeah you know yeah i got you we
all live together bring your family
married bring your family that's all
gravy
but don't let somebody else do it with
your money you don't do it
to your family does that make sense you
know i get you that makes sense though
yeah does that make sense
let me be talking [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it makes sense but yeah you're saying
that [ __ ] yeah i got it
cuz that's what's all about but how
could so many people love you
then so many people love you how do you
know people who don't love you
you can't be a knockout to everybody
somebody has to dislike you a life
wouldn't be balanced
yeah there's a bunch of people that
dislike me i'm not but this is what i
learned in life too
everybody you fight is not your enemy
and anybody that helps you is not your
friend
yeah i just want to tell them man listen
i'm the guy that um
it would be like one third of some [ __ ]
they used to get
one or thirty-third a month for you to
get to manage you and i broke that down
to 20 cents you went to managing your 20
cents right
because that's because of me he was like
a third of that [ __ ] yeah
you imagine i helped all
how much they used to give like thirty
third in the third some [ __ ] like four
yeah [ __ ] read read the history books
or stop them from that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's crazy 20 from
i'm 33rd in the third come on get the
[ __ ] out of here
man i got a good manager though like uh
yeah jay prince
james good [ __ ] jay is a good
dude like he makes sure like i'm
straight well
eventually you have to hold you again
23. yeah
but if eventually in life you're gonna
say hey i need to take care of myself
yeah i gotta take care of these babe one
day you gonna have a woman you love one
day
she's gonna get pregnant you have to
take care of your family that's when
that [ __ ] becomes
precedent yeah so yeah you can't know
about that
so yeah you know i mean those babies
is bigger than us yeah i got you no no
you don't
so i'm just saying that one day you will
yeah and don't get
to where they say you didn't take care
of your money and they say
hey daddy what happened to all the money
yeah you don't want to hear that
why do you say that mike does it happen
to you mike yeah [ __ ]
daddy got the money back yeah
but it's kind of like what you what you
talked about mike it's like you know
you learn from your losses man oh that's
what it's all about i think that's why
it's more beautiful now because you know
you made the comeback no it had nothing
to do with the comeback
[ __ ] come back everybody knew i was
in the gutter but now i'm doing dope
it's about this i want to be up more
than anybody in the [ __ ] world want
me to be
down no one can stop me i'm invincible
at my shirt my twins man that's what for
[ __ ]
that's on my show you're hosting my show
with me
anyway what's up man yeah
what the [ __ ] going on with you yeah
10 brothers and sisters
i got it's eight brothers and sisters
yeah that's what i'm talking about when
you got eight brothers and sisters
[ __ ] can't be
taking too much of the pie yeah right
how would you like to uh
end your career man like what would be
the the cherry on top for you man if you
could
i want to be a pay-per-view superstar i
want to be
a several division world champ
i want to be undisputed a few times in
several different weight classes
but i just want to be like a big
superstar like i want the whole world to
know like
like how mike tyson is like a legend
like i want to be a legend like the
world to know that i'm a legend
don't be a legend with no [ __ ] money
nah i'm gonna make sure
i stay awesome all of us said that
right but i meant to say that don't be a
legend like that yeah
unless you know to be bankrupt because
of the time they can't be bankrupt yes
once
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's cool mike man any would you like
to say anything to
mike mike tyson man before please are
you a legend to me like i respect you a
lot
like and you're a cancer like you're a
kid
[Laughter]
don't be giving all your money to the
[ __ ] girls man all right stop
stop giving your money until it's good
give it to your family yeah i got it you
just [ __ ] girls alone man stop
okay stop now but i definitely i looked
up to mike like my whole
upbringing then i used to like watch his
interviews and
listen to like the stuff he's saying and
i'll be like i laughing
crazy right
this should drive you crazy you know why
too much you gonna be crazy in a minute
you watch what
do you love her i love her what's her
name lyric
saying right here lyric that's her name
i love you on my larry heart
dude is crazy i'm telling you this huge
little man like watch out be
careful yeah i got you talking about me
watching a couple of years when he's the
superstar he wants to be
and what's her name again lyric okay
remember that i'ma still be with her too
i know you are mm-hmm but she gonna be
with you
you know we always think well maybe when
they leave her but she's gonna be with
you
no
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to think
aka triple c henry cejudo i'm mike tyson
we great we got the great shakur
stevenson thank you for your presence
brother yeah appreciate y'all too
thank you we're out of here
[Music]
you